thirty years since the beginning of
married with children yes that's madness
no I don't look a day over 45 actually
you look which you look absolutely
beautiful I'm wondering if they did a
reunion show would you would you squeeze
back into those what braise off all of
Delhi Bundy yeah no I don't even think
they make those in my size anymore right
I'm not that guy anymore do you know
what I mean like I'm a mom of a
six-year-old you have a six-year-old
how's that going I don't wash my hair
I'm not this is not a joke I literally
had to make Friday's hair washing day
because it would get to the point where
I couldn't remember how long it had been
since I washed my hair so to ensure that
there is cleanliness I call it hair
washing Fridays
okay so or my daughter just goes you
smell yucky mommy yeah your skin smells
yucky you smell you smell awful to me
ma'am yes she's six years old she's sex
oh my god well and and it's how do you
because six-year-olds are very
strong-willed and what they want they
rise yeah that was you agreeing with me
I wasn't me agreeing okay that's the
same sound with a nature Nancy - it is
the same sound and I'm tired of it no
one else on the bus likes it either
I just take it out laughing we're having
fun we are okay the but I'm just curious
when my kids were at that age they
wonder what they wanted and you'll do
anything to convince them no no we can't
do that what's your trick I tell her
stuff is closed for renovation
what do you mean Oh Disneyland's closed
for renovation she used to take
gymnastics and I wanted her to stop
because it was too much during the week
and she's like why are we stopping I'm
like renovations you're just lying to
her this is where you're supposed to
build her character by telling her I
know that's what she wants oh and Santa
Claus is okay and the Tooth Fairy is
okay but my real problem yeah
most of our children most kids watch
this show this is a children's show
primarily yes
hence the finger of Fiat joke that's how
classy we are you're lying to your
daughter I am and you just don't care
[Applause]
you